after losing a terrible game she managed
to pick herself up and win five in a row
carissa let me say congratulations for
being the u.s women's champion for 2021.
thank you how does it feel right now
i guess it still hasn't really sunk in
but uh
i'm so happy i can't stop smiling so
i mean i was really surprised to win
this game because i was like
i was mostly thinking like yeah nazi's
like really solid with white i'll just
probably have to fight out for a draw
and then and then tomorrow just try not
to lose
so this was really a surprise you played
an opening that we thought was a little
bit shaky-ish like it didn't
instead you played an opening the hippo
that
normally doesn't have a great reputation
yeah i don't know after
um
after she played d4 my prep was
i guess it was kind of iffy because i
was like i don't know what i'm gonna
play so i'm just gonna look at like a
bunch of different openings
and then while i was thinking about it i
was like
i feel like i'm fine entering like the
modern and like the hippo and stuff so
that's what i went for
all right you did get a very
a cagey type position
and then
just when it looked like she was getting
a grip on those light squares you played
this
this speculative attack with h5
and then it was right at this moment
that she played a move that we fell off
our chairs to see the move f4 what did
you feel when you saw the move lane on
the board
i mean i was so surprised at f4 she
so she can't take on like g5 if she
doesn't play f4 right because there's
h4 and then after g4 like bishop takes
g4 ideas which is what i was going for
that sacrifice doesn't seem to be enough
compensation but then i thought if she
kind of just like sat around i wouldn't
be able to do anything
because
um
the engine does give knight a2 is saying
it's very solid for him yeah because
like kind of the whole idea behind my h4
combination is that the pawn on f2 is
left undefended after the bishop takes
on g5 but here in this variation um
bishop's still on e3 so
so i don't really have any more of my
tricks and so i was very surprised that
f4 i fought gave me like a lot of
a lot of good options
but um
to say the least
yeah the one i liked the most was kind
of what i went for like with night g4
so
and she was kind of already getting low
on time here so i thought it'd be like
really hard for her to play
yeah your attack just spoke volumes
by itself and just a winning attack and
we just saw this
real beat down as your queen showed up
and then she desperately tried to open
up the game pushing your pieces to just
great squares and you were able to
finish this off in style at the end what
a game carissa you beat four former
champions
in this tournament that has never been
done in the women's game ever only twice
in the open what are your thoughts about
doing that
i mean
it's very crazy but it wasn't um
i didn't know that it was kind of like
the first time this had happened so
so yeah kind of a surprise i guess
pleasant surprise pleasant indeed uh you
are now the champ you've got
friends who no doubt have been
supporting you through this event what
do you think they're feeling right at
this moment and would you like to thank
anyone um
yeah first i want to thank
the kasparov trust foundation for
supporting me they've been uh i've been
working with them for like
quite a few years now so it's really
great
i feel like it's done a lot for my
growth as a chess player and i also want
to thank my friends who are watching um
everyone's like been texting me after
the rounds and they're all like let's go
and
it's really it's really nice to see them
following so closely
and
i want to thank my parents of course
because i couldn't be here without them
and they're probably watching right now
so hi guys
thank you so much for everything you've
done for me and
yeah
unbelievable fantastic results let me
just say you know we had to pick a
winner in this event on the very
beginning
and there are a couple of people who
have faith in you
me and var don't pay attention to the
peanut gallery over there as they didn't
pick you
just let's just get it straight so one
one check mark for for uh this side
uh carissa fantastic fantastic
performance the way you won
brilliant
now you've got one game to go it doesn't
matter for the score itself but a lot of
times you win the second to last game
and you get everything that last game
becomes a downer what is your attitude
going into that game
i mean
i don't really want to like affect my
mindset so i'll just go into the game as
usual
and
see how it goes but most of the stress
is off me now so yeah all right keep a
little bit of that stress you want to
make it six in a row if possible
congratulations you are the u.s women's
champion for 2021. uh carissa first of
all our congratulations from the peanut
gallery over here well done um it's been
a source of speculation on a panel
uh who you work with as a trainer i said
that in the past it had been larry
christian said i know you're a samford
fellow which allows you to choose
basically
any trainer you'd like the support is
the financial support is that great who
have you been working with you mentioned
the kasparov chess foundation
uh
tell us um
yeah so in recent years i don't really
have a
very steady coach
usually i just work with um
i work with people once
like right before a big tournament
um but like on the usual i don't really
don't really do much okay um
so i would have to say
probably alex ownership i've been
working with but these few years so yeah
nice so big shout out to alex
something's working between you two
again
charissa first of all my congratulations
at the middle uh of the tournament it's
felt it felt like you are in a slump
but after that
maurice roasted you
was that a catalyst
for your revival winning five games in a
row and winning a national championship
definitely you know i was i was so hurt
by liz ross this can't ever happen again
i have to play to play so much better i
can't that's that's all we do that shows
your toughness that shows that you can
take criticism and shows you're a
champion and that's how it works if i
had roasted chris christian would have
just wilted
come on
that's not how champions do that's how
it works we'll be honest when you play
bad you play bad when you play great
you're a champ that's how we like it yes
again bingo as we say five in a row well
done uh good luck carissa in the last
game don't lose your focus
yes i won't celebrate your victories
[Laughter]
what do you have chris and there it is
once again
applause
2021 u.s women's champion
well done young lady fantastic